[Music]
have you guys
ever needed to deal with someone
blocking your car
in every morning every morning is it
your neighbor or like you're someone you
live with so
my roommate gifted my other
a brand new truck yeah you got him a
truck for his birthday
what the [ __ ] wait say again sorry so my
roommate
got my other roommate which is the
assistant a brand new tractor's birthday
what the
what yeah and then now because we got a
truck dude
what kind of assistant damn they're just
balling like that so no assistant well
it's uh it's bradley and then
obviously they get to film youtube
videos on like surprising and so but
bradley bought him a
car yeah a truck is it can he paid or is
he doing the monthly payments by himself
nobody cares about the article what's
the insurance rate
but he got him the guy doesn't have to
pay for it so does bradley need more
employees
i know because you need another like if
i had a sick ass
assistant i would probably do the same
thing yeah because
us like if i had the money to because
assistant work
is probably one of the most valued
things
to get help on he does so much like
crazy amount
i i just had to go through two i need
more but then the thing is i can't even
i need to get myself a car you know what
i mean well if you hire an assistant and
instead of paying them cash you pay them
in a car it's
better taxes well think about it dude
like how much
is i don't know like let's dirty g's for
a tacoma
no but then you don't have to give them
a truck you could get them much civic
i wanted to know what the store so
that's okay okay so we already have
there's four of us that live there right
and then there's basically we have
enough room inside the
we have a gate that opens then you could
go inside right i live in a mansion i
got it yeah
so then it's already there's three cars
that fit in there so i have my spot
my my roommate mike that was on the show
he has next to each other
yeah and then uh brad has his truck that
parks on the side of him
then there's the garage where brad has
his other car um and then inside the
house for some reason behind the couch
is a [ __ ] motorcycle
but besides the point in another car
behind that couch yeah it's weird i told
you
to mention okay and then so this is the
driveway in but because he got a brand
new truck he doesn't want to leave on
the oscar where all the trees are and
then all the dirt and everything that if
you leave your car one day out there
it's covered
so he always parks it but like every
morning i have to get out and either
have to tell him
but now he's really good about waking up
at 6 a.m and gonna go work out
so now it hasn't been an issue but for
the month that he's had it every single
day
what would you do if similar situation
but it wasn't your roommate it was like
some stranger you don't even know who
owns this car
yeah i would tell you it's it's way
different now because now
if you really need to get somewhere just
uber like i don't know who the [ __ ]
blocked my car
you could uber but back in the day
without uber it
probably pissed a lot but say you call
the truck company and then you get an
uber
it's not like your house are you leaving
from it's like say you you're at the
somewhere like an hour away like a park
you're not going to uber and then come
back like you stop this
it's happened to me before where my car
got stuck in a parking lot because
someone was behind me
and so that pissed me off but there's
nothing i could do i didn't know what to
do you didn't
call a tow truck or anything no i had to
i think i talked to the management i
don't know if they ended up towing the
tow truck but then they also don't cut
they're not like the cops so they don't
call they come at their convenience
take it too long so i needed to go
somewhere so i think i just called a
friend to come pick me up
dang i'll remember when friends used to
do that yeah that's
like what are you doing i'd do that
forever can you take me to the airport
people are like when you ask them it's
like a burden for them but i'm like the
second you need something i'll do it
same i'm like well fine then i was just
like i don't like asking for favors
i don't like asking for favors but i
like being asked of and i
i feel it makes me feel important all
the time oh cool i get to help you i
don't like to
i don't like people to ask me favors
specifically the airport pickup thing
though i used to love the feeling of
like when you're gone and then like you
know you come out of the terminal and
customs and somebody's waiting for you
oh you know like that feeling that [ __ ]
is always going it doesn't matter who
you loved one of the things can you pick
me up oh can you just get uber
oh we still get that when we visit his
parents though so that's nice and they
always kind of pick us up
oh wait my cousin too i pick up hyrule
next time yeah
hit me up dude my girlfriend's not
picking me up i hate when my mom picks
me up man
things go slower yeah she meets me at
the airport and she's
lost on the way back i'm like how do i
know how to get back to your house in
japan better than you
she gets lost going to the same places
it's not even public transportation for
you in japan
it's public and she's like which train
do i take and i'm like you've been here
for [ __ ] 20 years or what
when she picks you up from the chain so
you don't really get picked up you just
like
she meets me yeah yeah why does she even
come then
i just think she wants more time with me
dude
it is it is but it gets annoying because
um
what you have to consider like is her
her memory is her memory okay is it
deteriorating
no it's okay so it's always been this
way so there's following etiquette right
if someone's following you somewhere you
don't [ __ ] zigzag throughout the
station
oh i don't do that so like in a car
sense like it's this it's it's like if
the light turns red you don't [ __ ]
put
you don't put the pedal to the metal
because there's ten people following you
right
but then that's literally my mom she has
this one track
mind where she's like oh we gotta take
that train don't we all right i don't
give a [ __ ] who's following me
i'm just gonna go here here run over
here go ask this person over there
go all the way over here and then i
noticed that my stepdad
caught on so then me and him we just
stand there and then we go all right you
think she got it all right
and then she runs back and she goes okay
why weren't you following me because
we're like
cause the station's right there you took
initiative
to zigzag all over the place to figure
out the information on your own
especially with those glasses like just
be like i know what you're doing mom
so i have someone that relates with me
we're like yeah yeah that's what she's
doing huh
yeah so now i just started going and i'm
like all right i know where to go just
follow me
and she was like man i like i like going
with you because it's easier
oh yeah she's like i don't have to think
and figure it out yeah
you can't block someone in the train
what do you mean
yeah so back to the story oh yeah that's
true being blocked in when you're
good exactly so toby
maguire this is toby he's 49. would i
look like that [ __ ] he looks like the
derrick shovin
you know the guy the [ __ ] bruce
willis dude kind of from the nose up
bruce willis all right derek shelvin and
bruce
and then the bruce willis head yeah he's
got mel gibson's ears
[Laughter]
he has brian callum's hairline yup who's
that [ __ ] breaking bad
no no
the stand-up comedian okay anyway so
tell me here
he and his wife have spent
a lot of money to create one of those
like drop curb thingies that look
similar i guess like
they added something that's a lot of
money huh well they no no so
the driveway that they have because in
their street it's always packed with
cars
so they created like a driveway thing so
they could park inside and not on the
street
but the and so they have this sign here
so people don't block that that driveway
so they could come in and out
and so one day there was this car that
kept showing up
blocking that driveway and his daughter
really needed to get out
and but she was being blocked in so he
ended up leaving a note on
the the windshields asking the driver to
please remove their car
and to not block that drive so nice he
also pissed on the tire afterwards oh
well so then he ended up uh waiting a
bit
like you know no one moved the car like
the car was still there
day after day and stuff so finally just
multiple days just got
fed the [ __ ] up yeah and covered the car
oh [ __ ]
in this uh saran wrap kind of hey that
looks double
part the luggage
[Laughter]
bro yeah so he was just like ugh
let me just get the point across but not
harming the car
and so he can't get in he had recently
gotten this
a shipment of this material oh [ __ ] he
just [ __ ] wrapped the whole thing up
and then eventually the owner of this
vehicle came out
and saw the car and was kind of laughing
at it too they're like that's that's
really [ __ ] clever
but they it was a girl and she was very
apologetic and promised never to park
there
i didn't know but that like just posting
this photo on social media
it got a lot of attention because it's
like well that's
one way to not harm someone but also get
your point across like do not park here
you know
so a lot of people it's hard for them to
get back in the car i thought the note
would be the
thing yeah i guess it wasn't i don't
know no that's way better
i mean if everybody just had a bunch of
telephone order like that's way more
effective that's but he put a note
and then you said day after day she kept
parking there like it was hour after
hour
uh well they did say the next day was
the car was still there
also she probably was like getting some
dick so
she she was sleeping overnight and then
uh
she didn't read the note well yeah they
were saying that this car was blocking
the driveway about two to three times a
week so that's why i'm saying
like a lot of days yeah so she must have
saw the note right yeah she's all like
i don't care why do people even do that
you know when i go to like a parking lot
you know sometimes the way they draw the
lines
they run out of space right so like
let's say especially like a corner
so they run out of space and then you
see like like all these parking space
especially in
tokyo this all these spaces are filled
you see there is one space here but you
also know
if i park here technically i get to get
out but this guy is never going to come
out
so i just avoid the space yeah because
i'm like thinking ahead yeah why do
people like not even
do that like would they just go [ __ ] it
i need my convenience is more important
than anything else i think a lot of
people think that way
yeah people are very selfish absolutely
yeah well also the way that they
they design those parking lots like the
spaces don't they do it in a way where
you both can park here and still kind of
get out some of them you can't somehow
some of them
that's like some of the ones are like
it's either one or the other or if it's
too many coopers maybe
but you know our cars keep getting
bigger every single year
so it just can't yeah i hate those
parking spots too
but yeah so like i said the driver was
just very apologetic
laughed it off and said that's very
funny i won't park there again
and then he ended up saying like i'm not
a nasty person i just like to get my
point across and the funny and harmless
it only took her a few minutes to take
the wrap off her car and it was cleaner
than before
because of it yeah he isn't messed up he
would anyone could have told the car
yeah uh we didn't feel like it's their
fault if they told you you did it
it's called no parking well what
happened i don't remember don't park in
my parking space
wait was it the homeless joe one no it's
joel plays the korean guy
parking yeah no parking i was this guy
yeah you don't even need a wig now
to play the character don't park in my
parking spaces
and then what happens
don't park i forgot i think it's not
blocking parking but it was like someone
you know when you have a signed parking
in an apartment space
and then we always had this problem
where like we would show up and
someone's in our [ __ ] space and we
kept barking what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] bishop if you live in
like a community like condos or
apartments
there's like someone always in your
goddamn space goddammit [ __ ]
i just hate tandem spots in uh los
angeles i hate those
both in like valet parking and then in
your own apartments too i have a tandem
spot
so like anytime you like come home late
but then it's like
because you came home late you know what
i mean like my girl she'll like park in
front of me but then i know she has to
leave early
so if my car's dead then i'm like damn
it so i gotta go upstairs and like go
grab her key while she's like sleeping
or something and switch the cars
that's really considerate of you though
can you set yourself up for success for
the next mornings then you have to wake
up early to move your car i do
i do good job but when i don't do that
because i'm tired
i'm sacrificing the next morning because
i'm already tired in that moment i think
what sucks is we don't have public
transportation
yeah so i think it's like we do it's
just bad oh you're right it's not it's
everyone's
bad and it canceled uber yesterday and
it runs every 30 minutes
oh my goober and lyft yeah yeah la yeah
oh california i think it was the ride
sharing just uber right
no it's no it's uber and uh lyft yeah
well they were trying
to categorize that as a uh drivers as
employees
not contractors or whatever and then i
i don't know what happened but uh
they yeah it didn't work out well so
uber and lyft was like we're getting the
[ __ ] out of california
yeah but they're but they kept going i
don't know yeah it's kind of weird i
don't really know the details see
the entire taxi industry is like thank
god
yes i'm leaving california
i don't want taxis man what do you mean
like they're not that cool you know like
uber's cooler
like they're very inconvenient and
they're outdated and they charge so much
[ __ ] money yeah they're so expensive
dude
takes me a hundred dollars to go two
blocks and [ __ ] and
i never feel comfortable that they know
how to get to your house without using
your gps
don't do that i haven't taken a taxi
since like the early 2000s i don't know
because whoever has the directions right
but you tell the tax you're like oh i
live here and then they'll be like okay
like what's the cross
street and like okay and they'll take
you there they do know how somehow it's
so crazy the only reason why i do like
the taxi though is so you could go
hey taxi and then they stopped just for
that
[ __ ] yeah and they showed me like nah i
called my uber dog
it's fun doing that in new york i always
feel like i'm in a movie
taxi why don't you just call your uber
and then when you know it's about to
show up you're like
uber we do do that right anyway because
uber
it's not the same when you're expecting
[Music]